[Music]
vodka martini shaken not stirred
very good Mr Bond James Bond
all right cut sorry this is real vodka
yeah we have a sponsorship with Smirnoff
so we have to use real vodka so that's
fine but I mean no one can tell if it's
c12 what do you know about Skyfall oh
sorry sorry I'm sorry
c12 take action what do you know about
Skye
Oh tell me everything I know about
Skye's okay go again tell me everything
I know about stem what what is your wine
you uh you know tell me everything I
know about empty can we get that weird
boy in here there is weird boy yeah boy
look at how weird boy probably sleeps in
a racecar bed 12 take ten well you know
about sky wall give me a vodka martini
Jake it never stopped I'm a big boy and
I can do what I please give it a martini
with you sorry I'm sorry everybody I am
a professional actor and I'm ready to do
it so this for continuity this should be
over there right
hi vodka martini shaken not stirred
very good Mr Bond James Bond
that is stirred do you mind if I sit I
think it would be more natural for me to
sit spies sit watch me
I can't breathe man I can't breathe this
is the problem that's James Bond look
hey weddings over no secret just the 11
herbs and spices and racism I own people
don't act all mad this is gonna be great
for the bloopers why the blu-ray
available now Blu ray charles no picture
just sound hey i give your double O's
the 7 yeah why why do people keep asking
me that guys I'm gonna do James Bond
what do you know about Skyfall rolling
mm rod you buy Smirnoff it's not for
winos it's for classy spies
[Laughter]
my god I'm here just voiceover me
hey this isn't working for me
why don't we let's try something new
vodka martini shaken not stirred
drink it cherry boy that's a wrap on me
[Applause]
[Music]